brought to you by msi computers msi  number one in gaming find out more at us  msi com hey guys it is just mcdonald  coming at you from e3 with the GS news  update it seems the fans are spoken and  saved Shenmue and in record time Shenmue  3 was one of the biggest surprises to  come out of sony's press conference in  only three hours the kickstarter crossed  the 1 million dollar mark and hit its  goal of 2 million in 12 hours as of this  recording the campaign is just over two  and a half million bucks the original  Shenmue launched in 2000 in the US and  cost nearly 67 million dollars to make  creator yu Suzuki promise that Shenmue 3  would give players the full Shenmue  experience I don't know about you but it  seems to me that two and a half million  bucks and 70 million is a pretty big  difference let me know what you think  though and if you reckon the game can  meet fan expectations for more III  goodness stay tuned to gamespot